teddy spaghetti his name is teddy
spaghetti
it's a warning to us this is a warning
to us okay
revenge of the sis you've been making
fun of vox day and i'm here to tell you
that it's gone on long enough
i'm one of his elite karate fighters
and i've been dispatched to deal with
you
and make no mistake there are tens of us
this guy's the best what you can't
understand
is that vox day is a genius it's not a
coincidence that he has a few iq points
higher than owen benjamin's mom says he
is
and some people talk slowly
deal with
it that one made me laugh
this is what made me so you need to
prepare for war
because i know that i'll be the music
and i don't care what your trolls say
stupid
[Music]
karate this is your only warning
saying karate about punching he's just
so
childish and he's like in front of a
bowflex or something
i know the pull-up station
[Music]
pr liabilities revenge this is george
r.r martin george the dog gamma trolls
esp wheelchair-bound spaghetti this i
posted the link
holy [ __ ] i left a comment on this uh
video as soon as i saw it yesterday uh
it simply said okay i surrendered i said
i would say oh i wrote i just said i
surrender
we have somebody else making a video
threatening us
well that's nothing new remember this
guy day of the rake
that's hilarious actually but damn the
rake uh he made a video a few months ago
of defending teddy spaghetti okay we got
another one we got another one guys get
ready here we go
day of the rake this one's rough to
watch because do any kids take them out
of the room okay
the cork boards the best part
revenge of the sis do you remember us
oh oh oh oh boy here we go
here we go i've watched this let's say
listen guys pay attention to the idiot
the background
that's part of what why is the owner of
patreon coming after us
[Laughter]
all right sorry start again focus
revenge of the cysts do you remember us
karate karate because we were the guy in
the background
well that's how you do it royce you
actually say karate
[Laughter]
karate karate
the sis do you remember us karate
karate because we remember everything
roblox combination
after vox day teddy spaghetti theodore
supreme dark lord's victory against you
was fully complete
we've been largely dormant
we're still waiting for owen to return
from the mountain with the ten
commandments that his mother gives him
but you keep poking the bear's nests
hive
we've been trying to warn you guys but
you don't seem to take the hint
who do you think is behind coronavirus
who do you think is behind the riots
don't fly too close to the sun icarus
might get burnt
crush the water bottles in his face
this guy's [ __ ] hilarious i'll share
the link here today
i love that his i love that his analogy
he's very subtle these videos they're
hilarious
because even in and out his analogies
are [ __ ] up because he's like don't
fly too close to the sun
or you're gonna burn and it's like well
no he fell he didn't burn but it's still
very it's just everything
everything about this video is perfect
turpentine it says turpentine
god that's amazing yeah please share
that for people that's [ __ ]
hilarious these guys are amazing sir
sir god that was great that was one of
the funniest things i have ever seen
here i'm gonna i'm gonna share it in
here here you go [ __ ] brilliant
[ __ ] brilliant uh day of the rake if
you want to find him
subscribe so taylor ranked us out of the
chat
if you play your cards right there can
be peace
all right hey it's all right buddy hey
listen
we don't want to fight man we don't want
to fight
that was great dude seriously very funny
sorry well we got another threat from
day of the rake
you guys haven't been activated in a
while i know
it's time to go find out everything
you can if they surrendered bfm
we have an enemy you know what to do
i want i want to know what these guys
had for breakfast
yesterday
you are you are on go i love you fox day
i'll die for you
and um and so
uh you know
you guys heard the man we are code word
hot dish code word hot dish
let's get em boys
[Music]
revenge of the oh no do you really think
your surrender would get accepted so
easily after what you had done yeah i'm
afraid you've burned one too many fences
oh no and now we're going to make public
you're going to make secrets
here's what our research found mursh
oh no merch is guilty of having
pre-marital sexual intercourse
royce voice's search history
includes the words boobies
oh no next time maybe you guys should
make sure there's no skeletons in your
closet with other people
or hey
[Music]
just i respect that i'll back off we
haven't even been talking about them
frankly we haven't we've left them alone
what did you do to piss these guys off i
didn't do anything what did you do
i haven't done anything but i will say
the
the here's the brilliance of this
sketch that they did this time
vox really does
streams where he says things that cringe
where it almost sounds like he almost
sounds like a cut scene
in a command and conquer game right and
it's
it's very funny of them to be like oh
yeah we can just fake a skype call
he speaks like he's on a screen in a
[ __ ] starcraft game going
vfm i need sats on all the blah blah i
need sitrep
on all the following streamers like it
says he does it he gives
he literally just makes the cringe and
all they had to do
was layer it into the thing that was
[ __ ]
beautifully done boys beautiful day that
was
very funny as soon as i heard vox i'm
going oh they used one of his
actual cringe monologues because he
sounds like he's
talking to people who don't exist it
really is like metal gear solid
very well done that was [ __ ] very
funny dude
they rose to the the top
exerted dominance created chaos and that
was
bad perhaps a twist of irony
that in the end the dark lord's undoing
was as simple as his intellect
the most common and cost effective food
source
known to man spaghetti
[Music]
you understand you can't defeat people
like us because we're idiots